strengthening of the threat of terrorism
and the growth of ethnic and
confessional conflicts in this area this
contradiction separatist attitudes
lately you know of youth were
artificially escalated from outside it's
important that the actions of the
Turkish Armed Forces should be used by
the members of the terrorist
organizations including a guild whose
rival rebels captivated by the Kurdish
armed groups and who try to get out to
be free Syria should be free from the
illegal foreign military presence to
achieve a stable and long term
stabilization in Syria on the whole you
know of you it's only possible while
while observing sovereignty and
territorial integrity of this country
position important position how we
discussed in detail with mr. beragon
about it it's important that the Turkish
partners share such an approach to
protect the peace and stability on the
border of Turks and Syrians should do
together here without the respect
respectful cooperation between Turkey
and Syria I can't do without it one
should also launch a white dialogue
between the government of Syria and the
Kurds who reside in north east of Syria
it's obvious that precisely with the
framework of this inclusive dialogue in
full volume can be taken to account and
implemented all the rights and interests
of the Kurdish people of the Kurds as
part and parcel of the multinational
Syrian people the course of negotiations
with the president we of course
discussed the further steps on the
promotion of the peace political process
in Syria which Syrians themselves with
the help of UN will conduct within the
framework of the constitutional
committee upon its creation the
guarantee countries of Astana format
what thoroughly during the latest period
over many years we assume the situation
on
the ground shouldn't hamper this
long-awaited launching of this committee
next week already 29 to 30 SEC Toba in
Geneva of course of course we dwelt upon
the humanitarian situation we think it's
necessary further on to help the Syrian
refugees to return to their motherland
it will have to to alleviate the burden
of the social economic strain which the
countries bear who agreed to accommodate
Syrians of course include including
turkey and first of all turkey we appeal
to the international community
especially profile agencies of un to be
more active in offering humanitarian
assistance to all those Syrians who
return without discrimination
palletization and preliminary conditions
have been taken advantage of this
meeting we we took a bunch of speak to
discuss the the current issues of the
bilateral cooperation with satisfaction
stressed eternal war which increased by
60% in it grew last year we share the
views concerning how we should act in
the near future I would express their
certainty that the further growth
offered Lenovo will have the
implementation of the settlement on
payments and settlement in national
currencies which was signed at the
beginning of October we spoke about the
important document to which envisages
not just more active use of ruble and
lira and mutual trade but also the
widening of the acceptance of the
Russian cards in the territory of Turkey
and we switch on of Turkish banks to the
system of the financial messages of the
back of Russia I think it's one
important step on the way of widening
broadening of the tourists we spoke
about the whole complex for our
relations including huge projects which
are being developed positively most
military technical cooperation is
deepening we want to stress that in
Turkey in Russia there are cross years
of culture and tourism are conducted
finally I'd like to thank mr. Erdogan or
grants colleagues for this businesslike
and grant conversation which we have we
haven't and further on to promote our
cooperation know in all the direction on
the principles of good neighborliness
and the respect of the interests of each
other
but account but expressed satisfaction
that as a result of quite a lengthy
that's what we managed to reach the
solutions which after were statements
would be pronounced with ministers of
Foreign Affairs of both countries the
resolution of which you know of you very
important if not just fatal and will
help resolve quite an acute situation
which took place and the border between
Syria and Turkey distinguished members
of the press I salute you with my
sincerest feelings and respect we're
very happy to be in nothing I'd like to
to be in Russia I'd like to express that
to begin my words I'd like to first
express my condolences in up we knew
clear central to Russian citizens who
lost their lives I'd like to send my
condolences to them again the same day
in transverse the the bend the water
band in transverse 15 of Russian
citizens lost their lives I'd like to
also send my condolences to them
distinguished members of the press
especially today's discussions today's
deliberations our main agenda was Syria
and the developments in Syria but along
with that we also discussed our body to
the bilateral relations about economy as
the president's just expressed
we are going to increase trade in our
national currencies and the agreement
about this has been signed very recently
this agreement will be very helpful to
reach our 100000 billion dollars trade
relationship our collaboration on our
kuia is continuing and we have agreed
upon a calendar in the future our mutual
interests work will continue in order to
reach our mutual interest in here hey
bye when I mentioned this also we have
taken very important steps on defense
industry and we will continue to do so
with mr. Putin we have talked about the
maintain the establishment of peace and
tranquility in Syria we have have spent
a lot of effort those years effort on
that on Astana agreements as well
together with the Sochi memorandum we
have made very important agreements on
the 16th of September and Ankara
submitter we have declared the committee
a constitutional committee on 30th of
October Committee will be meeting for
the first time our expectation from the
constitutional committee is going to be
beneficial for the Syrians political
change and open doors for this political
change as Turkey all the steps we have
taken so far we have been very sensitive
in Ephrata shield and in olive branch
operations we have secured 4000 square
kilometer area and cleared it from
terrorists
this area that we have secured and made
safe 360,000 refugees have repatriated
voluntarily Syrian land was always
mentioned with terror attacks but now it
is reaching tranquility and peace
hopefully this will apply to the
northern Syria we have we are we have
been hosting three million and six
hundred and fifty thousand Syrians three
hundred and fifty thousands of them are
Kurdish these brothers these homesick
brothers should go back to their
countries and we should work on this
another important step for our operation
is to establish this the area that will
be safe with our operation first of all
we are going to repatriate 1 million
Syrians and after that another 1 million
will move back our plans according to
the plans regarding this we have shared
our plans with our counterparts
hopefully with the support of
international community this plan will
be carried out
in this process with our Russian friends
will work together and we are going to
make agreements on the repatriation
plans today with mr. Putin we had talked
about fight against terrorism
territorial integrity of Syria and
political unity of Syria we also talked
about we also we also made a historic
agreement with mr. Putin about Syrian
refugees we are not going to allow any
agenda separatist agenda in Syria 23rd
of October we have given 120 hours and
we have gave a condition that they were
going to move 32 kilo meter deep they're
going to be throw we are going to have
10 meter 10 kilometer deep area and
Russian security will operate in that
area in managed and Talib yard all the
YPG members will be removed with their
arms against leak of the terrorists all
the countries will take the necessary
precautions and there will be a common
mechanism to track them Turkey and
Russia as they've done always are going
to work together for a political
solution for Syria
my dear friends putting and the
agreements we made together hopefully
will bring a peace a new area that is
peaceful and tranquil hopefully this
Memorandum of Understanding is going to
bring fortunes for everyone in the
region as a neighbor of Syria and as
friends of Syrian people we want peace
and stability in Syria and we are going
to work with all our strength in order
to reach this I would like to thank mr.
Putin for his hospitality once more and
I like to give you my love and respect
you're watching al-jazeera we're
bringing you live coverage there of that
news conference from the Russian
President Vladimir Putin and his Turkish
opposite number read chapter 1 just if
you're just joining us here on al
Jazeera Sergei Lavrov now taking the
podium I suspect the Russian Foreign
Ministry break down on the reality of
that he's flanked there by his Turkish
opposite well let's just dip in and have
a listen to what mr. Lavrov saying as
well agreed on the following first both
sides stayed the adherence to the
preservation of political unity and the
third integrity of Syria and observation
of the national security of Turkey they
stretched their resolve to fight
terrorism in all its manifestations and
to resist separatist aspiration in the
Syrian territory in this context the
existing status quo in this current
operation Ian as it is depth of 20 32
kilometers will be preserved for both
parties confirms the importance of Adana
agreements Russia will contribute to the
limitation of an agreement in the modern
condition conditions v concerning from
2012 23rd october syria syria party in
the syrian-turkish body beyond the the
military russian police in syrian armed
border lines
what about force will be introduced they
will contribute to the withdrawal of
subdivisions for 30 kilometers and this
patrol should show complete within
hundred fifty hours after 1200 or the
23rd october from this moment will start
them joint
russian-turkish patrolling in the depth
of 10 kilometers from the borders to to
the west and east from the region of the
operation source of peace and fast from
the Qamishli town six of the
subdivisions of course and their
armaments will be will be broken on the
membership and terrified both parties
will take all necessary measures to
prevent the infiltration of terrorist
elements 50 will be undertaken joint
efforts to contribute to the safe and
ball and voluntary return of the
refugees will be set up a mutual
mechanism of the monitoring verification
for the observation a coordination of
the implementation of this memorandum
tells both parties will continue working
on this search of the political
resolution of syrian conflict within the
framework of the mechanism of Astana and
will support activity of the
constitutional committee between Turkey
and Russian Federation this is the
memorandum of understanding 22nd of
October 2019 so a Turkish Republic
president and attorney have been agreed
below one both sides are going to work
again work towards security and
political unity to terrorism in any way
and any type will be fought against
within Syria and the agendas that are
trying to separate Syria will not be
tolerated in tot and Syria 32 kilometres
deep withdraw world will take place for
both sides are going to according to
their going to act accordingly to Adana
agreement and Russian Federation will
make easy to apply Adana
agreements on 23rd of October at 12 p.m.
noon Russian police and Russian security
forces will be observing outside the
safe zone in 10 kilometer outside the
same zone the Russian security will
secure that YPG will be removed from 32
kilometers deep from Turkish border this
will be from
pleated and in that safe zone on the
west of it and on the east of it apart
from commissioners there will be Turkish
and Russian security forces observing
the area all YPG entities will be
removed from members and both sides are
going to prevent against the leakage of
the terrorists entities back to the area
H the secure patch reaction of the
refugees there will be a collaborating
work on this there will be a
verification mechanism to observe these
developments and within the Astana
process there will be works in order to
find a sustainable political solution
for the crisis in Syria and they will be
supporting the constitutional committees
work